Bộ tay chính ban hành kế hoạch tổng kìm kế tại sản công trên toàn Quốc tại thời điểm không dân ngày 1 1 1 5 ngày 2021.
Một tiêu là sát định chính sát số lượng, cơ cấu khiến trạng sự dụng và giá trị tại sản công.
Lâm cân cứ hoàn thiện chính sách pháp lật, lập bảo cáo tại chính nhận nước và bảo cáo thực hành tiếp kiệp trong lắm vi.
Pham vi kìm kế bảo gồm tổng tổng bộ tại sản công tại cơ quan nhận nước, đơn vị sự nghiệp công lập.
Tổ chức chính chỉ xác hội, đơn vị lực lượng bố trang và tại sản kế cấu hạ tổng gió nhận nước đầu tư, quản lý.
Bước chiến khai tốn thủ quyết định 2.8 ngày 2021.
Trong tháng 1 đến táng 1 1 5 ngày 2021, bộ tay chính ban hành kế hoạch, chỉ tiêu biểu mẫu và hành giấn.
Táng 1 1 đến 2.8 ngày 2021. tổ chức tập hấn nghiệp vụ.
Bộ tay chính, tháng 1 năm 2021 sáo hành thành tổng hợp bản quốc.
Các bộ quản lý nạn xây dự, nông nghiệp và mối chường, công thương, khoa học và công nghệ,
bán hóa thị thao và dù lịch phối hợp hướng giẫn lĩnh vực phủ trách.
Chứ ngày 15, 2021, các bộ, cơ quan trung hương và đế phương và thịt lập bán chỉ đạo kiểm kế,
chân bị giữ liệu và tổ chức thực hiện đúng tiến độ đầy đủ, chính xác, công 2 và mình bản.